this is your reminder that the BBC has
yet to address the consistent
transphobic leanings in its news
coverage and while the team behind
Doctor Who is not connected to this in
any way since this is a BBC owned
property I'm going to keep pointing it
out until the problem gets resolved
links in a pin comment below if you
don't know what I'm talking about I'll
stop saying it when it stops being a
problem
well I got a lot to catch up
on
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah so with the strike wrapped up
basically I talked about that earlier
this week uh I can start talking about
Doctor Who as I normally do do um the
situation I was under before was I could
still do reviews of new stuff so with
the specials coming up I was obviously
planning to do that but I wasn't talking
about anything else none of the the news
the promotional material none of that
and a lot has gone on that I have not
talked
about so this will not be comprehensive
but I'm going to touch on a handful of
things that we have learned or have
happened since um I've stopped talking
about Doctor Who I'll give my brief
thoughts and then I'm going to get to
what the title and the thumbnail teased
which is the overall concept of the
hooniverse which if you've been here a
while you should already know I'm a bit
nervous about and that hasn't
changed but we'll get there we got a lot
of individual things to go first first
of all um somewhat to my surprise Disney
is not going to be getting at least not
initially when they start airing the new
episodes of Doctor Who they're not going
to be getting the new who who writes to
stream those those stay at Max now like
if you're in the UK uh it's all on bbci
player done you're all set if you're in
uh the US and possibly other territories
but definitely in the US classic is
still on britbox uh and also 2B now I
guess the what has been up to now been
called the modern era we're going to
have to figure out something else to
call it now for a reason I'll get to in
a minute um but series 1 through 13
specials included that's still on Max
where they had been going um for
distribution in the US on streaming and
now the new stuff starting with the
specials will be on Disney plus as I
said I was a little bit surprised I
think I kind of assumed that the rights
for the modern era of Doctor Who would
have come with what Disney had gotten I
guess it makes some degree of sense that
uh Max had um distribution streaming
rights for the shows passed when they
were getting new ones that still struck
me as is somewhat odd cuz like to be
honest the streaming rights for the
previous series aren't as valuable if
you're not also showing the news stuff
but apparently there's a longer time on
Max's rights for the streaming than um
you know their ability to air the brand
new stuff so they're going to keep it
for now I'm still a little surprised
even after finding that out that Disney
didn't Pony up and just buy them out
from Warner Brothers Discovery I mean
Warner Brothers Discovery has been
selling a lot I probably would have been
willing to I guess it was a calculus
like we'll just wait except that you
know one of the main things that tends
to be a big part of mentality for many
often bad decisions uh within Studios is
the idea of anything benefiting the
competition
and yeah the uh viewing numbers for the
old stuff on Max is probably going to go
up because interest has gone up as new
stuff airs and so it's less odd to me
like it's distinctly possible that for
what it would have cost them to buy the
rights to get them away off of Max and
onto Disney that it probably might have
cost more than um what they would have
earned Off streaming those specifically
like it might or might not or might have
been
close um but I would have thought they
would have done it anyway if only so
that the bump doesn't benefit Warner
Brothers Discovery apparently not how
long is it going to be until all this
moves over to Disney plus don't
know at at this point don't know so
that's that's a bit annoying um we have
official word that shoy goa's first um
series first batch of shows is going to
be called season
1 which that's kind of what I said we
got to figure out something to call
modern era doctor who or what has
sometimes been called new who it's
obviously not now now it's a sectioned
off thing we now have classic who which
ran from 63 to 89 and now we've got
whatever we want to call this past thing
running from 2005 to
20 uh
2022 um yeah cuz it was last year that
power of the doctor came out and now we
have another thing that is just going to
be season one I'm not super shocked by
this given again the move to Disney and
The Branding especially if they're not
getting the rights to stream the other
stuff earlier I'm not shocked that um
that there's a desire to have it marked
as season 1 that having been said
there's another thing that came out that
does not mean that people should assume
that it is disregarding any continuity
including the Timeless child I've talked
about this before that I don't think the
Timeless child is worth reconning I
think it's a terrible idea and I think
they should just leave it alone and uh
Russell T DAV kind of validated my
opinion on that I mean he didn't say it
was a terrible idea he was much more
diplomatic because you know he said
Chris chold is his friend and his
colleague and he's not going to go out
of his way to erase all that now some
people actually weirdly interpreted what
he said to mean that he was going to do
something and build off of the Timeless
child he did not say that and I would be
shocked if he does minor correction I
guess RTD did say that there would be an
acknowledgement of the Timeless child in
one of the upcoming specials but I
personally am reading that as basically
just a line referencing the events
probably nothing in depth but we'll see
he actually uh in his statement did
bring up the doctor has a has a human
mother thing from the eighth doctor TV
movie that nobody has touched since cuz
nobody knows what to do with
it also nobody's gone out of their way
to rcon it cuz you don't have to just
ignore it move on that's what I expect
he's going to do with a Timeless child
that's what I said he should do with a
Timeless child so that's perfectly fine
I'm good with that there was a release
of a couple of uh tracks from uh from
Murr Gold's upcoming soundtrack uh we
got to hear the theme that's going to be
used for shikat was Doctor the track
called 15 uh theme for uh Ruby Sunday
the companion um the um upcoming version
for the main theme for the titles and
it's it's it's fine it's Murray gold
it's what it says on the 10 I'm not
super pumped about it to be honest like
this is with the caveat that I expect
pretty much all of it is going to play
better within the context of a story um
I tend to think of Murray Gold's scores
a bit like I think of John Williams
Because if you've ever actually sat down
to listen to a John Williams score front
to back there's going to be sections of
it that played fine in the movie but
like are not super Pleasant or like
great to just listen to um you'll get
that in Star Wars like just these weird
little little things that they'll happen
with the music and they work in the
films because there's context for them
but like just to listen is like and I
kind of get that feeling from Murray
gold in general and I did very much with
15's theme when it eventually kicked in
around 2 minutes 20 uh I got big I Am
the Doctor Vibes which I like I am the
doctor but but this was kind of why I I
wasn't really thrilled by the idea of
Murray gold coming
back I've heard this uh and and and I
understand that people didn't all love
the shift in tone that
happened um when we had chill's era and
it was a very we had a different
composer and it was a very different
approach to the music going much more
for am for Ambiance than bombast which
is mar Gold's thing but like just going
back to this I it doesn't thrill me it's
fine again probably play better and
it'll probably also grow on me when I
see it in context and it'll become
something that I probably get quite
attached to over time once I have uh
something to associate it with in a
vacuum just as a piece of music it's
okay same with same with Ruby's theme
and the and the main theme is just I
mean it's just series 4 again isn't it I
mean it it's not exactly the same but
like it's that ex excessive amount of
orchestration and going for that big
Orchestra sound that series 4 did so
it's just that and I do like that but
like okay I I I guess I guess people who
are like I need M gold back are probably
thrilled but since that wasn't me in the
first place I'm just like okay that's
fine so that all right there's a lot of
other stuff that was brought up now a
lot of what got talked about while I
wasn't talking was rumors I don't like
to deal in rumors I find them to be a
waste of my time and my energy because
nine times out of 10 they don't end up
being true in the first place so I don't
like sinking my thinking time into stuff
that probably isn't even true so uh
don't ask my opinion on rumors if you're
new here but let's get
to the spin-offs and the overall notion
of the
hooniverse I'm real nervous about this
because between the fact that we have
the word is multiple spin-offs in the
works one that we know for sure there's
a unit spin-off that's going to feature
Kate Stewart uh as a character and that
like as a general premise like
fine like yeah it it'll probably be a
less trying to be adult version of
Torchwood which is fine because attempts
to be needlessly adult were some of the
big problems with the first two series
of Torchwood but um you know it's a
spin-off okay and there's probably
others being worked on actually there's
almost definitely others being worked
on and they've already started shooting
shooty got was second season and we
haven't even gotten any of the specials
out yet much less had a look at him in
the
part now understand that when I say I'm
nervous it is not because I don't have
some degree of confidence in shudy gowa
as a performer in Russell T Davis as a
as a Creator as a writer as a person to
head all this up
but moving forward with this much
momentum before we've seen anything
we'll only
ever make me
nervous because it's been tried a
lot and
historically it doesn't
work when you move forward bold as brass
on multiple spin-offs and already
shooting a second season when you don't
even know for certain that people liked
the first season heck don't even know
for certain that people like the
specials much less like the first
season that makes me nervous because if
anything doesn't land right you have
already committed to a bunch of stuff
that people might not want
now I'm not surprised this is happening
between the money that Disney is pumping
into it then the desire just to sort of
bring it up to um sort of past Glory
quote unquote you know when it was a
little bit more ubiquitous than it's
been in the last few years and also
probably Russell C dav's own enthusiasm
like I understand doing this I'm going
to be nervous at every step I'm just
going to be because I've been doing this
a
while I've seen what happened to
Snider's DC
works I saw what happened to the Dark
Universe I saw what happened to the Lego
movie franchise all this stuff that had
and that one was probably best example
because it had the most good movies that
came out of it but it was still
diminishing returns across the board and
all because they had committed to these
multiple things either on the back of
only one success or before they'd even
gotten the first thing out like you
could argue that the SNY verse was
coming off the back of the success of
Man of Steel but Man of Steel was not as
Uber successful as you'd think it they
would wanted to be for them to move
forward with Batman v Superman and
announc five years worth of films based
completely in this universe and on this
vision and then Batman v Superman did
not make the money it was supposed to
and everything went to heck this is the
same reason I am nervous about James gun
and the DCU this is also part of why I'm
nervous about the current state of the
MCU now the MCU is the only thing so far
that has made this big interconnected
expansive thing in the realm of
Television movies work but even they
while they hinted at the possibility at
the end of Iron Man by having Nick Fury
show up they didn't immediately announce
everything that they were going to be
laying out they built it up they made
sure stuff was working because if Iron
Man had tanked they weren't already
committed to making up through two
Avengers films and all the associated
movies that were going to build up to
that they had already started doing some
stuff that could be isolated and could
be treated his self-contained if the
connections weren't panning
out none of it was dependent until they
got to the first Avengers movie which
was built up to but everything since
then is rushing into okay
so here's our thing and here's the
spin-offs and here's the additional
stuff and we're working on the second
year I'm like you don't even know if
people like it yet and understand I'm
not coming into this with any reasons to
not like it I'm not going I think it'll
be bad and that's why this is a bad
decision no I am very hopeful for this
I'm excited for the special I'm excited
to see Shiga I think it'll be good but I
still think this is bad way to approach
these things there is moving forward
with confidence and then there is
committing to something before you have
the slightest clue if the market is
there yes the fans are excited the fans
are always excited but you are going so
big on this you've got to hook in a hell
of a lot of new people and you are
moving forward already on stuff as if
you know for a certainty that you're
going to do that and that scares me that
scares me with a property that I love
because I love Doctor Who and I get
scared even when it's in the hands of
somebody who I have a lot of creative
faith in to do this approach because the
slightest
bump so much more money is going into
this now than than was the case before
any bump has the possibly be has a
possibility to Ripple out and derail so
much stuff now it's not just a matter of
oh okay so that approach wasn't ideal
let's adjust a little bit for the next
season oh wait you already shot the next
season and a bunch of
spin-offs and so now you're stuck with
them whether or not launching this far
this fast was strictly Russell T
davies's idea or whether was being
pushed Along by Disney Sony the other
you know the BBC all the major players
involved I don't know but this
feels this feels like a corporate
psh and that in and of itself makes me
nervous in regards to anything connected
with Dr Who Doctor Who has managed to
retain a certain amount of Scrappy charm
to it even at its height of popularity
even when it had spin-offs and also can
we be real for a hot second the
spin-offs have never been very good I'm
sorry Torchwood had one amazing series
it was children of Earth and the rest of
it had a couple of highlights and a lot
of crap
the vast majority of Torchwood is crap
Sarah Jane Adventures was sweet and cute
but if you weren't in the younger
demographic that it was aimed for which
I wasn't it was also something you
didn't need and was very disposable
perfectly inoffensive perfectly fine not
mind-changing not amazing clasp I still
haven't gotten around to see apparently
he's getting a re-evaluation I guess
it's not too bad but sure as heck wasn't
successful seeing people get so excited
about spin-offs especially the idea of
launching multiple spin-offs pretty much
IM mediately and this is the one room
where I will tackle people saying like o
they should do a spin-off with the
eighth doctor with palagan no they
should
not don't get me wrong I love palagan
don't split the fandom by having two
competing doctor shows going on at the
same time the spin-offs are not
necessarily a competition because it's
based off that but you give an alternate
doctor and now suddenly everyone who
doesn't like this doctor flocks over
there and it becomes a fan War whether
you design it or intend it to be or not
not no that's a terrible idea I love
Doctor
Who but when it starts getting this
big on the basis of stuff we have not
seen I'm going to be scared and I'm
going to be nervous and I want to be
wrong I want every single concern every
nerve that I have all this I want it to
be I want to be wrong across the board I
want to see the specials and have
nothing but joy I want to see shoy God
first season season one and just have
nothing but a huge smile on my face and
needing more I want the spin-offs to
feel like they actually contribute
something and are better than the
spin-offs that we got last time they
tried to do this I want the whole thing
to just fly and be
amazing but I can't guarantee it's going
to do that and until I see that it does
I'm going to be nervous I'm not trying
to drag down anybody's
enthusiasm but I've seen what happens
when wouldbe
franchises push this much this fast
before we've gotten Thing
One and yes you could try and argue with
me well Doctor Who is a proven property
yeah so was most of the stuff that was
supposed to launch a massive universe
and didn't this approach by and large
has failed and so seeing a failed
approach applied to a property I love is
going to make me nervous I'm still going
to hope I'm going to hope against hope
that it beats the
odds but I've got
nerves and they're not going to go away
they're Pro my nerves will probably
remain up until seeing Judy goa's first
season and if the specials are really
good and if that first season is really
good I can probably calm down because at
that point even if the spin-offs aren't
great I know that they didn't
accidentally skimp on putting resources
and effort and creativity into the core
thing and blew it on this side stuff
cuz I just need that reassurance that
they haven't lost sight of the core of
the main show needing to be really
good as long as they can do that if they
can deliver that then at that point I
don't care if the spin-offs suck well I
care a little I wouldn't care
much
but moving this far this fast always
going to make me nervous
and if I just made you nervous I'm sorry
but this this just my brain what are
your thoughts on any of this uh was
there any news that I didn't address
that isn't a rumor that you want to ask
me about drop it down in the comments
and maybe I'll reply or whatever your
thoughts are let me know Paton pays the
bills enables me to do this as my living
it's why I can't afford to get Disney
plus and actually see the new stuff when
it airs amongst other things there's
other stuff I do down in the description
don't worry too much about it though
what I really want you to remember
whether you're excited or whether you're
nervous you are beautiful you are valid
and you are loved you are the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned time to thank some patrons and
this time I'm going to say their names
as if I'm greeting them welcoming them
to a party Robin Moore zuman l fulla
goddess Elida tck the thing that goes D
in the anime Ruth goer the goeran Oliver
B solitary pictures rri Bogden Melinda
Walters Jen Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
forab likes the poodle Robin Powell TLO
Tracy scrapit angry Casper Dave Hall
Rosalyn Bennett have fun tonight and
thank you for your support I don't know
why I decided to do that this time but I
don't know I'm having
[Music]
fun
y